la visita de la congresista nancy pelosi
ha generado un intensísimo tráfico aéreo
en las inmediaciones de taiwán hasta 27
cazas chinos se han adentrado en la zona
de defensa aérea según el ministerio de
defensa taiwanés y 22 de ellos han
llegado más lejos han traspasado la
línea media que sirve de frontera
oficiosa es habitual en tiempos de
tensión que los cazas chinos saben tren
en la zona de defensa aérea pero es
muchísimo más excepcional que traspase
la línea media es el último síntoma de
la indignación supina china por el viaje
de nancy pelosi las rotundas medidas
militares que había anunciado en las
vísperas han cristalizado en unas
masivas maniobras en seis zonas
marítimas que rodean totalmente la isla
los escenarios de algunas maniobras
están dentro de las aguas que taiwán
considera como propias y apenas una
veintena de kilómetros del litoral eso
ha justificado que el ministerio de
defensa taiwanés hoy denunciará lo que
entiende como un bloque de facto tanto
marítimo como aéreo que contraviene la
legislación internacional taipei también
ha denunciado los ataques masivos de
piratas informáticos a la gran mayoría
de sus instituciones públicas